TIME FOR THE FASTEST-7.
FIRST UP.
MONICA LEWINSKY IS BACK.
SHE IS A PRODUCER ON THE
UPCOMING SEASON OF AMERICAN
CRIME STORY.
SHE WILL FOCUS ON HER AFFAIR
WITH BILL CLINTON.
AND GET THIS.
IT'S SET TO AIR A LITTLE OVER A
MONTH BEFORE THE 2020 ELECTION.
>> I AM EXCITED.
SHE SHOULD PRODUCE IT.
SHE'S THE CLOSEST PERSON TO THE
STORY.
SHE SHOULD PLAY HERSELF AND BILL
CLINTON SHOULD PLAY HIMSELF.
IT WOULD BE LIKE A REUNION FROM
A REALITY SHOW.
>> WHERE ARE THEY NOW?
WE KNOW WHERE THEY SHOULD BE.
>> YES.
HER LIFE'S STORY IS REMARKABLE.
SHE HASN'T BEEN ABLE TO MAKE A
LIVING IN THE WAY SHE WANTED
BECAUSE OF WHAT HAPPENED TO HER
WHEN SHE WAS IN COLLEGE AND AN
INTERN.
WHAT I REALLY APPRECIATE IS THAT
THE PRODUCER OF THE AMERICAN
CRIME STORY SAID I DON'T WANT
ANYBODY ELSE TO TELL THIS STORY.
YOU SHOULD BE THE ONE TO TELL
YOUR STORY.
HE INVITED HER TO BE A PRODUCER
OF THE SHOW.
>> THIS IS A MOMENT IN CABLE
WHERE SOMEONE ON TWITTER WILL
SAY THERE IS A MASSIVE SHOOTING
GOING ON AND FOX NEWS IS DOING
MONICA LEWINSKY.
BUT WE DID THE OTHER STUFF.
>> WHEN THEY SEE US ON NETFLIX
ABOUT THE CENTRAL PARK 5
FEATURING DONALD TRUMP WHO TOOK
OUT AN AD IN THE "NEW YORK
TIMES."
THIS IS THE ERA OF THE "ME TOO"
I AM NOT SURPRISED.
>> BACK TO MONICA LEWINSKY.
>> RYAN MURPHY IS PRODUCING
THIS.
I WATCHED THE PEOPLE VERSUS O.J.
SIMPSON AND SARAH PAULSON WILL
PLAY LINDA TRIP.
SHE WON AN EMMY PLAYING MARCIA
CLARK.
IT'S A STORY YOU NEVER HEARD
TOLD.
>> THERE IS NEW INFORMATION.
>> SARAH IS BRILLIANT.
>> WE WILL HAVE "THE FIVE" WATCH
PARTY.
>> GREG, ARE YOU SURE YOU DON'T